I dreamt of getting paid to play
basketball this was not what I was
thinking my name is Chris I'm a big
basketball fan and today I'm gonna try
to learn how to spin a basketball my
finger
no matter how long it takes I feel like
in the past when I've tried to spin a
ball my fingers it doesn't really go
while I can get it started and it kind
of just beers off I want to do at least
three consecutive seconds of the ball
just smoothly spinning I don't mean like
me veering around trying to keep it up I
just want to be able to stand here
casually and just have the ball right
here spin it I know what you're thinking
at home is that three seconds is not
very long but let's just see right now
let's just time out three seconds right
now today was a long time all right I'm
ready to go this is the first attempt no
help here we go solid 0.5 seconds
probably remember I'm trying to not move
that's why I'm so stiff but I just want
to nope
hit myself in the face here we go this
is the one
I'm not frustrated at all either so this
is fine not bothered that I can't get
this you'll see that potential I have
absolutely no say in what happens I just
spin it and then I hope that it stays
there and I think that's probably why
it's not working out well
people don't understand either like
seconds move slower when you're doing
this so irritating I admit it now it's
frustrating all right I'm gonna use
Google I feel like I'm doing something
incorrectly that's probably a simple
fixed all right
I'm quickly just gonna hit up the office
and see if there's anyone who knows how
to do this so in the meantime I'm just
gonna search Google for some tips how to
spin a basketball mind a basketball
obviously from your nails I have trim
nails so we're good to four to stretch
your fingers and arms I didn't do that
spinning a basketball too hard or too
quickly constrain your wrists or even
fracture your finger I've been out here
risking it all I didn't even know you
pick up your ball and you find the point
where the grooves in the ball meet at
the bottom oh I was not doing that that
seems very important you can Palm it in
one hand and use a flick of the wrist to
pop it up okay so I wasn't doing it
incorrectly I just sucked at it hold the
ball up with your elbow a little above
your hip I think I was probably all out
everywhere and start with your
fingertips pointing toward your body
that doesn't make sense cuz then I'd be
like this by the time you finish to
twist your wrist oh oh okay so they're
saying start with the book with your
fingertips facing and by the time your
you do the wrist flip to spin the ball
they'll be facing away from your body
okay everyone seems to be using one
finger so I'm gonna try that if I suck
this time I don't know what the next
step is used Google feeling pretty
confident we're gonna give this another
try there are a couple things I noticed
immediately I was doing wrong I was
going from this side they said you want
to go from the bottom I believe so I'm
gonna try to just start right at this
bottom point one finger
that was not any better or any worse
than I was doing before feel like we're
taking a step back here nope this should
not be that hard it got me looking at
this like it's a Rubik's Cube now I'm
like focus on it oh I'm gonna ruin the
equipment Oh most promising spend so far
I'm actually sweating now
like actual sweat is formed on my face
trying to spin a basketball why did it
take where all of them meet I feel like
that would make more sense yeah when he
does throw it it's meeting at this point
of the ball so I'm gonna try something
like that not the worst that was by far
than not worst one when you run it back
it's probably be like 0.7 seconds but it
felt good been hit in the face like 50
times by this
it gets a little better and then I'm
like oh I got this and then the next one
is it's been when the ball hits me in
the face it feels a little bit
disrespectful honestly here we go
that had to be like a full second oh I'm
bleeding we drew blood all that to learn
how to spin a ball oh I dreamt of
getting paid to play basketball this was
not what I was thinking we had a little
stretch where I felt like I was getting
better and then I don't know what
happened hey please
got some assistance please come save me
okay
okay well look here's the thing just
toss it up and spin oh I didn't realize
we were just supposed to spin it oh okay
so I got some help she responded to my
email thank you for saving me today okay
do you see some stuff I see something
yeah when I do it my finger kind of
bends right here your hand is like so
let me show you kind of how like that's
top of my fingers there we go she's
gonna slap it okay you don't have to use
this part no yeah you get a little more
I like to be on the grip of it like not
the lines is a little slippery okay
let's see how far we can get I'm gonna
follow your pointers oh there you go see
that was other things it's supposed to
closer it's supposed to land on your
finger mine kind of lands on this part
of my nail I would like to say that that
was because of my coaching it helps to
see someone do it another thing I forgot
to mention is kind of move with it like
if your ball is moving you can kind of
like save it a little yeah but not
moving cuz I wanted to look I want to
just go with it like if your ball is
falling okay since we go with it helps
yeah see how I'm moving with it I just
went all around here okay I'll leave you
to it Wow okay all right thank you for
that
we've used Google we've used a person
who knows what they're doing and I think
it's time to put all that together and
spin this thing real quick it's gonna be
easy jump the gun there
it's not the worst my name is LeBron
James this is how to spin a basketball
you said everything was gonna click and
I feel like we're getting there it's
tough to balance like where to move
within the momentum dies
Wow we're getting so close okay
[Music]
Oh nope definitely not that definitely
not that either
maybe a little close have nightmares
about this oh that was that's got to be
it
tie me oh oh let's see oh that's / I'm
good with that
that success that's what we set out to
do I feel good about that progress it
only took three hours which is a good
lesson that if you just want to dedicate
the day to something you would probably
be surprised what you can learn this was
just a few hours outside messing around
with a basketball but I don't know maybe
I might go practice some other hobbies
and see what I can get into